all right well for people who are
joining this livestream this is an
internal meeting of our incremental
language development effort for wolfmann
language mostly talking about features
which are going to be in the upcoming
version of Wolfram language some further
out it's kind of a an assortment today
and we are starting off with a rather
simple thing called authentication
dialog and I'm about to find out what it
does and hopefully this will say ask for
username and password fine so let's say
this is me and pass um and it comes back
like that great so this is just for use
on the right hand side of authentication
typically that will be like this right
and what are we doing here so this is an
example and what's this here so we're
saying here in this design it will say
public key
those are two different fields so yes
the list case is lets you specify
whatever field you want and the question
is whether we're happy with that second
element being the syntax for field name
initial value and masking how does that
compare to what happens in form objects
I think this is this is the we took the
example from form object during our last
meeting okay and if I said this for
example hmm that's really weird
what would do that what I was thinking
it was okay so that's really a default
value it's the initial value for the
field yes okay fair enough that makes
sense is that what we want for the
failure case I believe this is what
forms do no they give a failure object
is there information about what the
failure I mean in this case is going to
be the user cancelled well there's a
different way of doing that I mean why
don't you just look up what is being
done for forms I think I don't need to
let's not do that right now right here I
mean I can I can do that I guess for you
right here but it's not kind of wasted I
understand let's let's move on um I'm
good whoever's typing in my ear please
mute themselves like you
you
so that was that and if I do this and I
put in something crazy here I think it's
just gonna give me okay it's gonna do
that if I say cancel okay does that
um they didn't even
no there was a dollar cancel just
documented I don't know let's find out
that is a good question
I have to say I'm skeptical but let's
take a look
okay
okay well that makes perfect sense then
yes okay so you should do that for the
canceled case but I think the failed
case I don't know how to force the
failure here but I'm pretty sure that
forum functions have a failure object
that comes back make sense I'll chat
with Kyle about that
okay so let's take a look at this one
then
you
no boy okay so I received the spec for
this last week there was some work
needed from Carlo to get dynamic
updating a forms working properly and it
may not quite be working properly in
this bill that didn't because I set to
like it there and then it's suddenly
right because then it's some sort of
auto submitting thing that I've that I
have an open question out to Carlo about
and I don't know that Carlos code is in
fact live in last night's build there
may have been this is also a prototype
build so who knows what's going okay
okay um so this is okay so I'm just
gonna fill in random garbage here and
see what it does um and so this is now
responding okay okay that's really very
cool it's very nice okay what's this
kind of do in the cloud does this work
in the cloud
it will it won't use form objects at the
back end because form control doesn't
yet work in cloud notebooks so it will
be some custom assembly of pop-up menus
and input fields then will be pretty
much the same okay cool
alright so let's look at the end and we
can make this work in the terminal as
well and I'm where that's really nice
what's that I'm working on that today
okay
that is really nice so can I see
anything along those lines
I mean screen there's some examples in
the draft ref page of what the terminal
and the Wolfram script samples will look
like okay do I have to update my ducks
for the last ten minutes or something no
no no well we should do it just in case
because there will been a lot of stuff
going in recently okay so you believe
the documentation is also finished for
this is that correct I believe it's
ready to be reviewed yes okay did we
work on it before or did did you just
look at it in authentication meetings we
haven't done a proper documentation
review of it okay what are the other
things other than secure authentication
key do we also have permissions key and
things as an author there
is username/password there's password
there's permissions key and secured
authentication key and then you know
then the user can specify their own list
of keys okay so I mean we did discuss
the possibility of generalizing this
thing to be a more general you know just
get me get me random a random
Association of data isn't that correct
right well so there's nothing
particularly authentication me about the
design about the the functional design
this would work equally well for just
about any form object so this could
other than the auto masking and you know
the the forms that we choose to sort of
pre-baked this could easily have been
form dialogue rather than authentication
dial well but maybe we can have that
separately maybe we can have that
separately yes is there any reason this
needs to be experimental I don't know I
don't think so do you really want to say
displays shouldn't we say puts up a
standard or dialogue for entering
authentication information let's say
puts up I think we use that sort of
language right I mean we have we have
eggs
what input says well input requests
input okay right by the right we have
dialogue input does say interactively
puts up okay I've never really liked
that turn of phrase but that's what you
there I think it's better than displays
because displays doesn't suggest that
there's any well but but in terminal
this isn't putting up some new window
this is I see this
yeah that's not bad
yeah presents is pretty good that seems
to more or less work for the terminal
case there your log is using your
initiates actually it's useful here that
might be better
does dialogue work in the terminal you
mean dialogue input or do you mean
dialogue either one dialogue does
dialogue input probably does not because
that's a notebook world thing choice
dialogue does because it can okay but
generic dialogue inputs I don't think
that makes any sense should we say user
name password authentication information
since that's what it does
you
okay
you
okay
you
seems very reasonable to me
so there was one issue with the examples
and that is that the DA key tools was
unable to actually capture screen images
of the dialog rather than just showing
the output we used to have that facility
but we don't anymore well I don't which
is how important it is to build that
back out I think it would be nice to
have I don't think it's critical I think
it's pretty confusing here without that
I think we nice to have but it doesn't
mean only to hold up 11.3 for it exactly
ok did you do the netting for all of
these things and it's now the knitting
is undone ok do we need to let's not do
that right now
we got a different set of people in this
meeting we don't need to do the knitting
here so this looks good though
ok should we move on let's see
oh well we have a question from the
livestream the person says might be off
topic but does this interact at all with
standard HTTP requests that return a
code for o1 authentication required the
answer is yes right I mean this is this
is something that we can use for URL
execute is it not absolutely absolutely
in fact if cur link was new and in last
night's build we would have seen it we
would have seen this working already
right so what this is doing is and the
user here is sort is showing that that
there is a already a dialog for that
case and that's correct and the whole
point here is that we can do
authentication arrow and then we can
give the explicit username and password
if we want to which will then pre-fill
so for example we could do this and then
what should happen is if I go there to
go to a I don't know what what can we go
internal dot wolf comm or something that
may not require that the authorization
for me I'm something rather like this
oh well something is very confusing here
why didn't it pre-fill that hey this
fonts wrong there but be widened it
refill the username here I'm not sure
I'll have to look at how this is wired
in okay well location dialog directly
would definitely be able to get this
right so the question is how it's being
called from the curling code okay so
you're saying if I said that this is
it's just authentication dialog with it
with a rule delayed rather than rule why
because you want to delay authentication
until the time that you are lxq needs it
I mean I suppose you could do it
immediately when processing the
arguments yeah do you have an example
for this yes oh that's interesting that
failed do I dare to put my actual
credentials in here this is all broken
credentials in and it re-put correct
credentials in and it reassured that
dialogue so something is wrong here yeah
this is in the prototype Delta who knows
what's going on with that do you know if
that's today's so that I can track it
down later may know it's who knows ok ok
let's move on
we're ready to move on have a quick
question about dollar counsel I'm
thinking about it do you think it should
be a failure q object because right now
it's not but perhaps it should
interesting ok I think it's just there
if we're going to get the right kinds of
extremes
I kind of agree I think it's in the same
categories dollar what does it I think I
was muted no wonder people seem to be
ignoring me
so you know I'm not a hundred percent
convinced I mean right there is say
dollar aborted failure Q it is oh oh it
says so right there then yeah I guess my
initial instinct is yet probably well
what happens in for example a aren't
they're interrupted isn't there an
interrupted as well or is that no that's
aborted that's dollar aborted okay
exactly I don't know
can somebody I I think the answer is
probably yes but maybe you could send
out something to co.design and just see
if anybody had been and then we could
maybe have a slightly longer discussion
in LCC this is a LCC ish sort of feel
right so but when we just send up mail
because I think if anybody's going to
object there's gonna be somebody we're
not expecting who's gonna object-- to it
okay makes sense okay let's move on all
right
I am unconvinced by this suggestion okay
so right now we have communists
right um I don't really believe in this
I'm sorry I you know I think most of the
time I yeah I can't I can say that I
don't think I've ever wanted rarest yeah
it's a rare function let's let's move on
I don't think we would need this but
okay let's some next thing here this is
funky a bit interesting so this is a
generalization of repeated timing I
think that correct mm-hmm
I think so I think the name is
definitely wrong but so let's do I don't
know what we can do here let's say I
mean something that won't cash I'm
trying to just think of something that
might write repeated timing is currently
one art right so we could add a second
argument we could which gives up I think
let's just check it as one ugh no or at
least T seconds well I mean we could add
the third argument and we could but I
think the question really is do you want
to give a distribution so for example we
have a similar issue with ping time
right so if we have as a good place to
sing um
the waiter met getting our node on
twitch saying that it seems super useful
to him but but which thing is super
useful profile or okay um okay let's
just look at this for a second give me a
website that isn't totally fast to ping
I don't know I don't know that might be
boobs BBC co dot UK who knows
um okay so then let's get 20 pings to
that um okay so ping time is some um
okay actually we've got some comments on
the chat that are sort of interesting
about rarest for a second here someone
is asking for a function that shows the
most frequent rare words in a string
right that is essentially tf-idf which
we were supposed to have as a top-level
function does anybody know what happened
to that because we certainly have tf-idf
as a net encoder I have no idea where TF
IDs is term frequency inverse document
frequency
it is a do you remember some discussion
about this with Alan's group when we
were looking at word frequency data but
there was sort of a discussion about
building up the corpus for it and it's
been many months and set discussions I
don't know where that well we were going
to have a thing that gave one so we have
word frequency right right what word
frequency data rather if I say word
frequency data of rare it will tell us
the frequency of the word rare in
corpora um
so
was if I say word frequency
data is with respect to a certain corpus
right there's a second argument that
gives the corpus specification well I
know there isn't yeah it's it's based on
the engrams database okay but we talked
about having other possible corpora yeah
I don't remember that discussion was
kind of a rabbit hole that went off into
a different direction I don't know what
we ended up doing was respect to other
corpora but that was one of the things
we talked about right okay zatia n-- for
an arbitrary but the tf-idf thing is
something that I have always thought is
useful and um the UM what on earth
happened to that where did we what where
is tf-idf I know we have a tf-idf in
something here oh my gosh that's funky
Oh feature extract yes yes yes yes yes
yes this insane place to get okay look
look okay let's get a little piece of
text um was a good place of text
take
see text sentences of Wikipedia data
armadillo
, five just have a piece of text and
then the claim would be Oh what on earth
is going on there
what just happened something really a
trake appetizing armadillo there was
something related to a change in the
Wikipedia API that was being looked at
well that better be fixed because that's
a big thing that's something that's
being looked at by some other people
that I say can somebody can we make sure
that that actually gets done um okay so
let's take that and now what we're
saying is feature extract of that
armadillo text and I think we probably
want to say first of that don't we ever
no no how did though those are multiple
sentences well who knows um feature
extract that tf-idf am I gonna get
something totally stupid there okay what
on earth is this okay
magnificent no idea what that is um
okay so
don't quite understand what we would
actually returned from tf-idf I know we
thought about this a while ago can we
can we put that into the let's put that
in the aisle d-list and also ask um who
is peering here is it Sushma okay can
you ask Jerome and yeah whether they
have some sensible suggestion for what
tf-idf could do as a top-level function
it seems a little questionable to me
okay let's come back to this and what I
was talking about was ping time you know
one routinely wants to get the
distribution here maybe but I don't even
know what this means what does this mean
this is a plot of what a distribution of
the times it took that's pretty random
I don't understand what this is yeah I
have no idea what that is either I mean
there's clearly all sorts of interesting
internal profiling data okay I just
don't know what this is so we'd have to
ask Daniel for more input here let's
let's do that Sushma and move on right
now okay okay let's move on to cached
function okay this is interesting it
seems to me so what this is is it's
analogous to once and this was suggested
I'm not sure who suggested this um just
like we can have local cache of
something like um actually what is the
local cache thing so that's the local
cache of a cloud object right of some
particular cloud object will store a
local cache of that cloud object I look
at that beautiful multiplication sign
that we saw there let me just look at
that again just to admire it oh how nice
um let me just see what I can really
admire it properly
yeah and doesn't work in that case
hopefully let's sign no that that's
correct it's not correct it is correct
it's sign it's it's a mathematical
function times the opening of a vector
okay but in the case of plot yeah no
that's ridiculous
yeah it would be woefully besides the
fact that would be impossible to
implement I think it would drive people
nuts and they're worried why does it
matter that there's a multiplication
sign there it is multiplying it because
people don't want to see them their
implementation people make that mistake
oh look they just put one in that's nice
of it when did it put it in okay hold on
let me see when it put it in Oh what
happened there that's interesting I like
that very much so
all right well what happens if it's not
in plot oh I'm sure well let's see sine
x times X Y Z
mmm very nice okay they tell you happy
yes hopefully yes because I would be
very angry if I son implicit
multiplication sign there no I um Wow
okay I thought we were doing like a
mathematical function not a mathematical
function thing but apparently you've
completely changed the heuristic since I
was last time
Oh sticks have been tweaked because this
case I view this case is really nice
because that's gonna save a whole bunch
of you know elementary errors okay look
at that that's nice too
and I really like the fact that it's an
X because it kind of suggests something
is wrong even though you know we know
it's a time sign anyway this is
something we should have added a long
long time ago I'm very happy about it
right now okay
let's talk about cash function so the
idea of cash function is that it
automatically sets up a memorization of
the function similar to the way that
once does it function once doesn't set
up a memorization something once right
well it caches that one expression
exactly exactly so yes so was there any
more details Sushma to that suggestion
here about cash function great okay y
really have G and F being different so
then we want to have some sort of I want
to cash I don't see where we need two
names you could have G of X blank equals
once of some expression and that would
think that would no I don't think so
because what this is saying is every
time that we look look we have the you
know we have this type of right oh yeah
and wouldn't once do exactly that no
yeah oh you're saying no because the
once only does it for the actual once
expression right and and every time yes
but you're going to literally be
substituting in the value of two right
so f of two
you're proposing that this is f of X
blank colon equals once rate of f of X
why does that work why does that work
because then every time an X is
substituted in that thing is evaluated
the first time in every subsequent time
it'll just look up the cached result let
me think about that so yeah but but
that's assuming because you say this
symbolic expression on the right hand
side that it's delivered by the delight
assignment just that expression right so
right if you if you now when you
evaluate f of 2 it's going to evaluate
once of F of 2 so the first time F of 2
will be with that hmm all right
we don't think this is right because
because we need to actually define what
f of X is I mean it's all very good
thing it's this but right so it's right
so boiled then we could say right it's
it's G of right so then you could say
it's G of X let's do this so let's say
it's once of x squared there right okay
so now you're saying F of 8 and and and
make it make it exactly exactly so let's
say print X actually let's do this let's
say echo let's be modern say echo of x
squared okay okay so f of 8 echos
magnificent F of 7 echos F of 8 doesn't
echo is this that seems pretty
reasonable to me
it's cool does it
okay is it efficient should be right
because it it it creates a hash-table of
some sort of the expression once right
once works by creating a hash table of
things that's evaluated yeah I mean you
know in terms of how to present this
yeah I mean okay so let's just write for
the sake of argument let's just go
something let's just write Fibonacci
this way okay let's just check that it
actually works okay so what you're
saying is that it's fib Avernus fib of
and once a fib of n minus 1 plus for the
van minus 2 and then we're saying you
know a fib of 0 equals fib of 1 equals 1
okay so now we're saying fehb of so now
just let's check this so let's say
feather of 10 or something that comes
back and we'll say fib of 100 and comes
back nice and fast well that was easy
I think that's even quite a reasonable
looking piece of code what do other
people think Jose what do you think
about this it looks fine to me and I was
thinking I was looking at at how once
it's implemented and it seems fine it's
you seem persistent value okay oh that's
right that change it was using a hash
but now it's using persistent value so
you could you could even make it
I guess persist across sessions if you
wanted to which might not be right once
of xfer is equivalent to once of expert
colonel session right but if you made it
more persistent than that then that
would actually be quite useful right
because if you have something that takes
a long time you know you don't need to
start from scratch after you reboot your
computer I think this is wonderful I
think the main bottom line here is we
just have to promote once a bit more
impressively I don't even know where
once is and we probably also need to
give some examples so who is dealing
with the once documentation is that
Roman or somebody else yes it was Roman
yeah it was Roman army yes
so we should put some examples like this
in there and we also need to make sure
we can add this to some pages what
wherever we discuss that kind of dynamic
programming solution which has we've
been talking about for 30 years the you
know we should be talking about this
instead this is very cool we should
probably go through and look in the
documentation for where we've where
we've talked about dynamic programming
and so on if you can if you can try and
look at some of those things and then
then we also should figure out where we
should mention once and like in the
functional programming pages we should
be mentioning it let's see do we want to
have a quick look for that um I would
like to actually get through our whole
agenda today kind of should be here
somewhere
I think because you can use it in
functional programming right put it
anywhere well do you guys want to come
up with some suggestions for where to
put it
I dunno I would have to think okay fine
all right
to be continued okay well so then this
this suggestion can go away because it's
already been done good okay let's look
at this one
okay so this is
yeah so the suggestion here is that we'd
be able to get session information just
like we can get system information we
should be able to get I mean there's a
crazy thing that we haven't had
something like this I mean if I say
question mark at sign you know I'll get
this kind of crazy list here I've no
idea what those are this is this is
getting weirder and weirder and some of
the things that are present here I don't
even know what these are
um but who knows what those are but but
in any case the idea would be that we
could do something like session
information and then we could say
something like defined functions and it
would give us a nice um data set of
defined functions what do people think
or data set or you know symbols with
values and the session information
open/close would be some kind of
interface that is like the system
information interface but about sessions
and this would include timing and memory
and things of that good do why not
I mean it's anything you know yes why
not I mean in other words one of the
things probably the default would be to
show on the front page defined symbols
and defined functions right so if you
just do session information open close
this would give you kind of the state of
your session what have you defined
you've got X to find you've got this
you've got that what's a function good
question I mean right so I mean I think
who's down value with a doubt with a
defined down value we can also get have
a more technical name there but but the
basic idea would be to do something like
this for a session
go ahead restricting to global I guess I
mean how does he know by default I mean
but look what it could do this thing
here would do that perhaps or at least
things on context path will be the right
thing to do oh right there which are
not in the system not in system yeah
well we have quite a lot on dollar
context pass
you mean that really like that okay well
fine so that would have to be tweaked a
bit but the basic idea here is to I
really think this is a good idea
to be able to have some kind of panel
that gives you the status of the session
and particularly people have asked for
ages and ages and ages having a you know
just a nice little table of what
variables are currently defined yes so
we need heuristics here to eliminate
dollar variables and this sort of thing
which are kind of two internal yes I
agree it needs some heuristics so and we
can do you know the open closed version
can can use a bunch of heuristics just
so I what to display on the front page
you can have a thing where you press a
you know you you click one of these
things to go and look at more detail etc
so I mean I'm not sure exactly you know
I think we should just try and start
building this I think it's a rather
straightforward thing to build we should
just try and start building something
that has the sort of similar design to
system information I think also once we
have this we can imagine some kind of UI
thing that will pull up session
information possibly even from a menu or
something makes sense yes yes I had a
comment what was my comment there's
waiting for you to finish in my comment
try to run away right so certainly
things like this right including like
you know oh I know I was going to say
right so system information is not
something that dynamically updates right
so no it does dynamically update very
small very small pieces of its update
but there but the purpose of system
information is not to show the state of
the system now it's to freeze-dry
a snapshot of the system so that people
can communicate I have a question
Lord this is really bizarre yesterday I
was looking at this in another meeting
and I was really surprised that my
keyboard wasn't showing up but today my
keyboard is here on the same Hardware
same machine I can't explain that mm-hmm
okay the phantom keyboard let's just
take a look at one thing just to see um
that is the weirdest thing I mean I was
sure I had always seen the keyboard on
here
oh that's just crazy weird that's a
different version right now for example
if you were to disconnect one of those
monitors I don't think they would
disappear although I don't know that for
a fact they don't the only piece of this
that are that are dynamic are these
openers that seems about to open here
right and notice the checkbox at the
bottom that says show dynamic values
because really the purpose of this is
not to be dynamic but it's a useful
thing know which button is the scan
previous track button cetera right what
do you mean I mean so it's so wait a
second
if I OH if I press something on my
keyboard nothing's gonna happen here is
that correct
if you press one of the things that's
reflected in this display well I did I
just messin okay so I'm gonna press I
don't even know where the skin I don't
know if the binding is correct or you
know but if you had a if you had a
joystick attached be able to see it
dynamically Yeah right
otherwise my mouse not listed here okay
it's it's now some it's not the club the
driver isn't declaring it as a mouse
anymore so system information doesn't
see it would be my guess great right
okay fine but so your question
implicitly here is does such an
information return an object I mean this
thing here if I were to ask for head
of percent 32 it rather bizarrely will
be called a system information data
object right which is the correct thing
yeah and so yeah similarly for session
information we want to do the same thing
it will be very nice if session
information could be dynamic is there a
reason why it can't be well I I don't
know that it necessarily should be
dynamic I'm right because you might want
to know you know what was the state of
my session when I did blah
I guess lu lu may have a clear answer as
to what would be the costs and benefits
of making the default zero argument form
fully dynamic but certainly i think some
of these things will not want to be
dynamic it depends on what you're
showing right if you're showing some
small number of variables and value and
their values symbols and their values
then that cost is minimal if you're
showing something whose value happens to
be you know thirty megabyte thirty
gigabyte data set you know there's
there's there's going to be a cost which
we won't necessarily know before trying
to display it well but so long as we
wrap it appropriately and short until
and we shouldn't write that we were
right but we would need to be like right
continually evaluating some function
that scans all of context path and
applies whatever heuristics and Whittle
sat down and I don't know how often that
would be I guess this is something we
could control the refresh rate but but
right but if well okay somebody by the
way points out on the live stream that a
pallet with a variable editor would also
be very useful right that's the issue as
soon as you give somebody the ability to
see these things they're going to want
to change them and clear them and remove
them and rename them all within the same
interface absolutely
and well that's a lot of work and what
do you want to give up in order to make
that happen
unless you have a magic clone Lu button
we have a clear use case for this and
what people have been asking for it for
a very long time for which mostly for
the thing which displays I mean what
they want is the first thing they want
is something which displays the values
of variables which is where they can
immediately see Oh I've defined X and y
and z and they're this and this and this
okay now they probably want something
beyond what you know they probably want
something a little bit more detailed
which is to be able to you know know on
which input line that variable was
defined etc etc etc I mean this is
clearly mushrooming into a more
complicated project right because they
want to be able to click on that in this
display they want to be able to click on
it and and go and see what what the
actual input line where X was set to
five was right which is completely
impossible turned on yes unless the
debuggers turned on right because the
curve the kernel has no idea what
notebook evaluated what much less where
and notebook but there are some things
that could be used for like a dependency
tree of the functions you have defined
and perhaps that's not so difficult to
compute a dependency tree I mean there
are many of these meta functions okay so
look question for session information is
there a realistic fairly lightweight
thing that we could do that would
actually be useful
that will show sort of the basic
information about the state of your
session that includes variables that are
defined it includes memory information
how long the sessions been running
those kinds of things possibly if it
knows it which notebooks are connected
to that session well that's not a
meaningful question assuming this
session is a colonel session right I
mean yes yes so right so certainly I
think we have how much time has elapsed
since the beginning somewhere if we
certainly have current memory in use max
memory used you know depending on sort
of what your ristic heuristics we use
it's probably fairly lightweight to get
you know global systems which are not
secret dollar variables with immediate
values and those with down values and I
don't know if we want to worry about
other values okay you know on our live
stream um two comments sheet is
spreadsheet kind of editing is sometimes
useful as one statement which is a
little bit different from this issue
because that's that's something that we
do have coming supposedly with table
view of table view ever gets finished um
if I'm not mistaken does table view is
table view in the system at this point
yeah I don't think it's table view I
think it's yes it is oh it is and I
think it even works Wow why have we not
told the world about this because you're
using the prototype build and they're I
mean why isn't it wasn't it evaluating
something well maybe that's what reasons
why it hasn't moved from the prototype
build I mean the last status that I got
from John on this was that oh it's there
in the in the head branch build it's
there oh
interesting but it doesn't evaluate it's
not only does it not evaluate looks like
it's getting stuck I mean that's quite
lovely by the way we've got a bunch of
background noise here so right get stuck
it's it's actually uninterruptedly stuck
okay well it may be that make expression
rules were never created for it although
why that would create something and
uninterruptedly stuck actually doesn't
isn't right then it should just fail
it's not finished and last I knew John
you know basically Aaron had a sort of
completely you know a complete thing and
John thought that you know there were
issues that needed that he needed to
review and and make sure they were
worked through so I mean this is I
thought it was and certainly you know it
does seem to allow editing um what does
it do
okay does the horrifying thing that
spreadsheets do that is disgusting
but I guess what people are used to and
it has some bizarre behavior here but
the string like thing okay um we should
find out what's happened to this
ah people on the livestream have have
now repeated this themselves and confirm
that it is in the in the pre-release
version of 11.3 okay but it obviously
isn't working properly well this would
be a good thing I mean I guess this is
for parth but for goodness sake let's
not have John work on this in any way so
Lou do you know who is the person in the
front end group who is actually working
dealing with this I'll communicate it's
it's it's Aaron that's the person who
wrote this but I mean right John is now
going to allow this to go in without his
seal of approval
absolutely I just would like to know the
status okay okay question so the
question of a the variable editor
palette I really do think we should look
at this and whether that comes from a
session information thing or whether we
just view that a different way by the
time we have dynamic and so on it really
you know to mock up something like that
is not difficult there are clearly
plenty of gotchas in it um but it would
seem to me well or is it difficult I
don't know
it would be a good thing to try to mock
up
Lu I think that's in your area although
an editable table of variables and
values yes I think that's the thing
people would really really like and
functions or we're talking just about
own values are we talking about but
let's start off with our values
generally with I can't cross that bridge
I mean that the the more complicated
bridge is obviously more things but that
I don't think we need to go there yet I
think that would already be quite quite
you know let's see my recollection is
one we've looked at this before and I
have to say it's been a while that we
have it has quickly descended into
utterly complet you know into great
complexity by the way in the eleven
three release build there from last
night at least on Linux the tableview
evaluates just fine for me to itself and
let's see if I edit it if it will yep
it's working just fine so I think it's
something with your particular builds or
maybe there's a Mac specific issue we'll
need to hunt down okay well this is an
11 point - Wow
ok it's generating an internal error in
eleven point two whatever that is okay
and eleven point two it evaluates what
how do you actually get the data out of
it anybody know well is it low look at
that what do you know that's pretty cool
this is pretty useful
use this for a bunch of things but I
guess it doesn't work with strings and
so on also I think the graphic design is
really sucky because it's basically
emphasizing the the headers and you know
these things more than emphasizing the
data which just doesn't make any sense
all right very quick okay so the few
things there but let's just have a
really quick look through some of my
list
okay so cached function we can actually
now take off as having been you just put
that into I guess that's in the done
list because it's it's achieved with
once right so I can go ahead and put
that um cached function is no longer in
this list and it just becomes those over
here um okay session data we just talked
about dynamic yeah this is an
interesting one this is something Lou
will probably have a comment on um
dynamic display so what is the point of
this this is what is the point of this
oh yes this is something where we're
simply saying give me a plot okay
other way it looks like your kernel is
still stuck in this session oh that's
bad um by the way we're hearing much
typing somebody mute themselves
okay so we have a plot and imagine that
we could say dynamic display of this
plot and all we get is the analog of
what we're doing in dynamic Geographics
okay know what I don't know what that
means
well where does it think we are I don't
know thinks we're in Champaign okay fine
um so you see what it's doing right it's
moving in the coordinate system here
sure right yes so the question is and in
this particular case it is able to
generate higher resolution stuff here
but my question is why can we not do
that just with a ordinary graphic so in
other words let me let me make a more
sophisticated graphic let's say I make
an array plot of I don't know array
let's see rule of UM cut we've hearing a
much background noise by the way um
co-prime queue of that let's say like a
table here I goes to 100 J goes to 100
okay so let's make a more realistic case
of this
so there's my array plot actually let me
make that a thousand instead
okay all right hard to see now wouldn't
it be nice if in this plot right I could
do the exact same thing that I'm doing
here with dynamic Geographics right and
so there's two issues one is that array
plot and plot are very different in this
respect cuz plot if you zoom in you
don't really want to just zoom into the
things you've already calculated you
want a fair enough I'm more interested
in the array plot okay if you want to
pan then that's that's easy enough to do
but either whoo but for a ray pot you
have all of the data right there so it's
so it's exactly analogous today right no
I'm more interested in the in the case
of you know the dynamic Showcase that is
purely taking graphics objects and being
able to zoom on them right where the
back end instead of tiles being served
from a server is just a graphics
expression that seems straightforward as
long as the graphics I mean there's some
out of mode as well yeah I mean I would
say that this I mean let's let's just
see what it's like because in this case
look I could make this huge let me just
try something here okay if I say dynamic
we have interactive gestures for doing
this kind of thing in 3d graphics
already don't we well you're suggesting
that this is something I mean there's a
scroll and a 3d graphic are you
suggesting that this be a feature of all
graphics objects or are you suggesting
I'm not necessarily suggesting that I
was just wondering or trying to remember
what we do for 3d graphics for 3ds et
graphics you can somehow move yourself
and look around which is kind of
confusing at times but okay so I'm going
to try this and see whether this works
see actually what I want to do
it's not right actually what I want to
do is this I want to just take that and
put that an image and I want to make
that simply a dynamic image and I think
all of us do Wow that's funky what does
dynamic image do and so I think it wants
an image that's kind of weird and silly
of it
okay all right what's wrong here so
image on its own of this should just
work now there we go
great okay so now what does dynamic
image do why doesn't that work
why does well let's see try percent
seven okay some sort of evaluation
problem I mean nobody here has worked on
dynamic image as far as I know right
well this is a bug Sushma this is for
you go get it track down um it would
seem to be straightforward to build I
mean based on dynamic image to have
something like dynamic graphics seems
like a straightforward thing I agree the
only question is what you're raising is
should it happen by default well in
other words for example in particular I
mean 3d graphics are also different in
that they don't correspond to the I mean
you're viewing them you're sort of
looking into the screen to view them
they're not represented you know as a 2d
region fine all right well why don't we
investigate what happened today lemak
image and then let's see whether we can
make a dynamic graphics that is of the
same type although obviously it's not
working on the bitmap right it's working
using the same control expression right
Yeah right but but then it would the
controls would look basically just like
this right so wait
first of all well I get I guess we could
have a little wrapper although I'm not
so it seems that dynamic image is
basically just busted right now
completely none of the documentation
examples work okay but right so I guess
I'm not sure I mean whoa
right so dynamic in certain eleven to
dynamic image of graphics of disks just
plain works and yeah and you can zoom in
and pan so I'm not I don't think we need
a separate so you're saying if I do this
right so you're saying it's horribly
anti-aliasing this thing well that's
because you're you right you mmm there
that 72 DPI or something crazy right so
if you say you say that what I'm doing
here if I did a rape lot here you're
claiming that this would work hmm I
might be wrong hmm okay well by the way
I think this shape well whatever
what the heck is it doing well address
trace that's right well that's just
crazy right so that's what we don't want
to do right we want this to work without
rasterization no it's really just a
question of you know of drawing
something with the right plot ranges
yeah do we want to continue soon here
interesting question I mean I would find
the the jump zooms just fine I don't
know what the UX for a continuous zoom
would look like what do you think I mean
the continuous zoom for a 3d object is
with the scroll wheel I have been
exploring interior fix the possibility
of having a continuous um
and for the most part these works really
how by I see by by having the tile and
then but but doesn't the tile have
anti-aliasing issues aliasing is rather
yeah yeah we would have to accept those
Geographics already does in the sense
that Geographics presents trying to
defund Geographics forever yes yes yes
and we're still working on that but but
but this seems like just a formula for
getting more fast by allowing it to go
between rendered zoom levels yes but it
also gives a more continuous experience
which and and and at least for graphics
because we would have to render graphics
that would be there wouldn't be a
problem in that sense presumably well
that's worth looking at but why don't we
try to see whether we can get something
that just makes use of the same UX
framework that dynamic image users and
see whether we can make a dynamic
graphics that works that way I don't
even know a lot of graphics what's it
who knows about dynamic image well
somebody in college team but I would
imagine if you ask I'm thinking piata
maybe I think my gosh okay all right let
me just ask about a couple of other
things here which happen to be on my
list Auto flatten which is turned into
flattened what is the status of that we
have been discussing their syntax and
what they're what what is this it's it's
a version of sequence in the same way
that nothing Sebastian of sequence
bracket bracket okay that sounds like a
terrible idea
no sorry I in the absence of a much more
compelling argument than not necessarily
I'm going to stick by my initial call
wait wait okay we don't need to discuss
this right here but Jose you what you
were saying you were you are
investigating it yes yes we're working
on the syntax and the properties and the
second argument
all right so what yes but what does this
thing actually do let's let's not do
that in this meeting okay okay let's
let's find then we can move it to the
LCC meeting where I can yell and scream
about it fine you're gonna like this
function it is I'm not I am not
convinced we we already know you're not
convinced you like it more with every
moment you spend implementing it okay
does anybody know I've just I just want
to check down the station a few things
and then we're going to move to a
different meeting um the the n-body
evolution stuff is that being handled by
you guys or is that I know Rob is
working on that but who's tracking that
as far as I know after Rob's prototyping
nothing has happened
okay any other meeting mm I think so I
think I think we should discuss how to
proceed okay I'm just got a few bits and
pieces that are listed on here but just
a quick note Michael track should be
involved in that meeting definitely um
Oh find equational proof I was told you
would have a status report on that here
we merged it yesterday and we have been
working in recent days on the
typesetting and we are still and
completing the documentation so haven't
heard in the last few days from Jonathan
he was working on the axiomatic theory
so my impression is that we will just
have many examples with different action
theories rather a hobby now an
accessible repository for the moment we
can think of so we will agree which is
kind of put it in the data repository
well but the problem with their data
repositories that we cannot instantiate
the variable names exactly I see so the
alternative idea was to create an
axiomatic theory funk simple that would
return yeah which is a cool idea which I
like at the moment I think we we don't
enough material to put there and it
would be nicer to think a bit more fine
okay just put a bunch of examples then
exactly yes we are thinking also how to
reduce proof object for the synthetic
geometry okay talking of which what
happened to the functions line through
circle through etc they are under
vigorous discussion and will be having a
meeting about them tomorrow and they
mean well I need to I don't know what
their current status is in part because
I need to review what they've sent me
and see how much I need to yell and
scream tomorrow okay um whatever
happened to what is it called around
around its it no we didn't match it for
for eleven three so we are still working
on on these and in particular we need
functions of the can handle it and and
performer for returning it etcetera so
okay it's gonna be very nice yeah yeah
and this is going to be very useful but
okay and yeah there will be also an
update of the visualization functions to
handle plots with crosses and ellipses
Exeter good all right okay we got more
stuff I would like to go over which is
in my big long to-do list but we'll do
that a different time um all right okay
by the way for fee people who are on the
livestream we're actually going to
continue that the next meeting happens
to also be being live-streamed and the
next meeting should be for those some
the end of the network packet capture
story um so okay so for people um so I
think nobody in this meeting is probably
in that meeting as well so see you guys
soon